if you are somebody that is sitting
around waiting for some external force
to come and do the work for you that is
such a losing bet it's unbelievable who
is it that their opinion means so much
to you that you are going to play small
for the rest of your life so 25 years
old online I'm getting my money right
I'm done no more excuses no more crybaby
no more blame rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's evan my one word is believe and i
believe in you i believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that i want to
see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your cup of coffee and sip on today's
message stop waiting for permission over
to you Mel Robbins a lot of you feel
stuck because you're waiting for some
kind of external force to either push
you and pressure you to change and to be
great and to be amazing or you're
waiting for somebody to give you
permission you're either sitting back
because you need some sort of external
motivation from somebody that's gonna
push you or praise you or pressure you
in order to change or some life
circumstance like maybe in your past
you've experienced trauma or you face
something really scary and that was the
thing that made you change and then the
second thing that people wait around for
is permission
look those may or may not come in your
life if you are somebody that is sitting
around waiting for some external force
to come and do the work for you that is
such a losing bet it's unbelievable
maybe you'll get lucky maybe somebody
will come but more than likely no one is
coming
the only kind of force that will truly
create change in your life is you the
internal kind of force I hate to say it
but for those of you that feel really
really stuck and you keep thinking that
somebody's got to pick me or somebody's
gonna discover
somebody's got to give me permission to
write this book it's it's ridiculous
this is external versus internal force
and what you have to figure out if
you're stuck is are you the kind of
person that is guilty of needing wanting
and waiting for external forces people
an event some outside force to kick you
in the ass if you'll finally do the
stuff that you've been dreaming about
doing I want to tell you something no
one's coming no one the people in life
that get what they want are the ones
that aren't waiting for an external
force to validate their dreams to
inspire them to give them permission
it's the people that realize that
success but happiness that control it
comes from the internal force and what
is the internal force it's you it's you
it's you being able to realize that no
one's gonna do the work for you it's you
realizing that you're never gonna feel
ready
in fact even as you start working toward
the things that you really want to do
you're definitely not gonna feel ready
and you're gonna feel outside your
comfort zone and that's normal when you
start to feel like you're stretching
yourself and you're sticking your
scrawny neck out there and you're taking
some risks that's amazing cuz you're
growing the minute that you start living
your life and start running your
business based off of what other people
expect you to do or think of you as the
minute that you lose think about the
people who you are listening to 95% of
people wake up and drive to a job that
they hate every single morning they
believe life is just the way it is and
there's no opportunity for growth and
it's always somebody else's fault and
they're stuck most people feel stuck
these people who you are so concerned
about their opinion of you are they
living the life that you want no and so
why do you care so much about what they
think
why do you limit yourself based on the
opinions of people who are not chasing
their dream who are not doing the thing
that they want to do if someone is
giving you advice if someone is telling
you their ideas on something if they
have not done what did they
you want to do than their advice is
meaningless to you and you need to stop
caring about their opinion it's holding
you back and forever will until you can
break free of it and let me tell you
it's not easy to break free you mean to
lecture Li know it you may know you may
know you know he right you know in your
heart that I don't want to think this
anymore it's not just that easy to snap
through it's not easy to ignore the
decades of social conditioning that have
been put on you because we are trained
to care about what other people think
about us we are trained to play small we
are trained not to stand out we are
trained not to go off and conquer our
dreams we are trained to be in the
system and so it's not easy but the way
through is every single time this is
this is one of the most important
exercises that I've ever done and
continue to do in my life into my
business that have catapulted me forward
countless times because every major
breakthrough that I make in my company
comes from me making a major
breakthrough with myself comes from me
breaking through a limiting personal
belief and so the exercise that I do is
every time that I can catch myself
worried about doing something based off
of somebody else opinion of me then I
force myself to do that thing even if
it's scary even if I don't know how to
do it even if I might fall on my face
even if I might
you know fail in front of that person
and be judged if I can catch it that's
the key because most of the time you
don't catch it most of the time you play
small by default you play small
automatically but when you can catch it
and it may happen in the moment or it
may happen a day later but if you can
catch it just before your bill to take
that small action then you need to push
through that fear you need to push to
the paint and go ahead and do it so a
quick example hayden my son loves to
wear different colored socks always he
never wears the same pair of socks
together at the same time and I love it
personally I love it I love that he's
bucking the system I love that
doing his own thing I lovely doesn't
want to wear matching socks I love it
then I go and I start folding my socks
just did the laundry and there were a
couple extra socks in the laundry that
didn't have a matching pair and is about
to throw them away and I thought huh
well what would Hayden do I just had
this conversation with him and I was
praising him but I'm gonna wear
different colored socks why can't I just
wear one gray with one black and the
first lock that came into here was what
people are gonna think I'm crazy I was
about to teach a class at China dance
also that night and I said I can't go
teach a class with a gray sock and a
black sock people think I'm nuts and I
caught it I caught it I was so happy
that I caught it because as soon as I
caught myself saying being worried about
what Sun levels gonna think about me
that I knew what I had to do I had to go
wear that black sock and wear that gray
sock and not only that I just wear it I
went to class and I rolled up my pants a
little bit some people could see it and
it's all the story around it and I used
it as as motivation and courage for
other people that wanna do the same
thing too for the people in my class who
are learning how to do salsa to also
think about limitations they're putting
on themselves who is it that their
opinion means so much to you that you
are going to play small for the rest of
your life and going after your dreams
and chasing the big thing and try to
conquer the world do some big mission
right doing that requires changing the
way things are done on a normal basis
will require ruffling some feathers will
require many people saying that this is
crazy this is stupid this is never gonna
work and so you need to decide which
life you're gonna live are you gonna be
the person who chases your dream who
does the big thing that you want to do
hey Hayden I'm tilling to start about
different colored socks look at this guy
one socket one what do you say to
somebody who says hey how come you have
different colored socks on what because
I'm different because you're different
and you're awesome I love it
this guy step up take that same approach
you are different and you are awesome
one of my favorite quotes of all time is
from Quincy Jones that legendary
producer who said not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your opinion of me
and we can get to that place and when
you can start catching those moments
where you were playing small because
you're worried about somebody else and
when you make that decision that I am
NOT going to play small in this arena
right now today I'm gonna embrace the
fear I'm gonna push through it and do
that scary thing and I'm willing to fail
in front of somebody else
and I don't care what you think about me
because the only thing that really
matters is what I care about me what you
care about you you're different and
you're awesome now I've got a special
bonus gift for you but before getting to
that I want to know what is one thing
that you are afraid of doing in front of
somebody else you're afraid of their
opinions their judgements their thoughts
about you what is one thing that you
have been holding yourself back from
doing because your mom or the internet
or YouTube or your friends are gonna
judge you leave that in the comments
below and I want you by writing it down
too to release it I want to help you
release that and go and attack it today
because that's gonna be your big
breakthrough to take off your goals
leave it down below thank you guys for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to in yourself and
whatever bye guys
I'd like you to fast-forward to 70 80 90
years old right fast forward in your
mind to that age 70 80 90 100 110 if
you're really optimistic whichever one
it is and I'd like you to write down
what will be the things that you'll
regret that you didn't do
imagine you're that age ask yourself the
question what will I regret that I
didn't do know what you did do but what
you didn't do
write it down make a long list right now
get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do on your phone don't do in
your laptop actually get a pen and paper
and write down your answers and what
will be the things that you regret that
you didn't do right really think about
it would it be you know learning a new
language will it be moving home will it
be telling someone you love them what
will it be what would have been write it
down right now now the incredible thing
about this question is that you're using
the future to empower the past whatever
answer you have in that question
whatever your answer is you can do it
right now today starting today because
you're not that agent and if you're even
if you're 64 and you're tuning in 70 80
90 you're still there right it's still
possible you can start doing that right
now it's empowering the present with the
future there is nothing stopping you
from making it happen right now you
don't have to feel that way when you're
70 you don't have to feel that way when
you're 80 you never ever have to feel
that way if you start doing it right now
and you can do it right now even if it
feels impossible you can start working
on it right now you can start trying
right now you can start making plans
right now because you're not there yet
and this is where you start this is
where you start making it happen it's
all in the now I was broke you
understand I was broke when I was 25
dead broke I'm not talking about
financially broke let me tell you
something no I didn't have any money in
my pocket I didn't have any credit cards
nobody would give me credit okay didn't
have a driver's license okay 1970 Ford
Maverick had a 1970 Ford Maverick no air
no heat no door handles the freakin
floor was rusted okay I lived in a 275
square foot apartment maybe 300 square
feet if you counted a little step out in
the front of the front door pay 275 a
month and I was late almost every month
so don't tell me about you money
problems man okay don't tell me about
where you were born
don't tell me about your bad brakes
don't tell me about what your daddy did
or your uncle felt you up or something -
some kind of weird thing - you know I'll
ruin your head or your sister abused you
or whatever okay look we all got
problems you got to fix your problems
now you got to get you money right so 25
years old I'm like I'm getting my money
right I'm done no more excuses no more
crybaby no more blame I'm getting my
freaking money right raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion can
not one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's something to me I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details